our series a more perfect union aims to
show what unites us As Americans is far
greater than what divides Us in any
child's life it's important to have
someone to look up to whether that's a
parent a sibling or a teacher but
finding a mentor who fully understands
you can be hard particularly when you
have a disability and lankiano went to
Farmingdale New Jersey to meet a girl
who found just the right person to look
up to someone who in turn found a little
role model in her
okay
like other five-year-olds Colby gerbero
spends a lot of time in a world of
Make-Believe here you go thank you so
much but her reality has differed since
birth Colby was born 17 weeks premature
at one pound two ounces she's faced a
host of health challenges since
including the muscular disorder cerebral
palsy or CP CP is where you have like CP
and and you use like Locker or cane and
wheelchair these days Colby is realizing
that others sometimes see her
differently she said Mommy I don't like
when people stare at me Mom I don't like
it I want them to stop I want Colby to
know that she can pick up the phone and
call me for whatever reason Steph roach
was also born with CP she and Colby's
mom Amanda met through social media
where roach a former CrossFit trainer
and book author posts about her life and
defying expectations when I saw Colby
and then I saw the way that Amanda was
guiding Colby through life it was just
like we were meant to to be friends
until now it's been a long distance
friendship the derberos in New Jersey
and roach in Arizona ready come on out
but one January morning who is it
they had their first meeting guess what
you're talking I guess what I got I got
the same thing in you
they were immediately comfortable with
each other can I pick you up
you're the best stuff I can't believe
like you're here
I love you Colby realizes that people
are starting to look at her and see her
maybe a little bit differently so we've
had some big conversations about how
that might make her feel and yeah I I
know all about how I feel now is it okay
to tell somebody that you don't like it
yeah we have to be nice about it yeah
but you can still tell somebody that I
don't really like how you stare at me
like that if you have questions I can
answer them for you right yeah if people
have questions they can ask you
after Colby went to play roach
remembered her own childhood I wanted to
be as quote normal as possible but it
really wasn't until I turned probably 20
22 where I really started to own who I
was with self-acceptance came new
chapters a growing circle of friends
success in Fitness competitions and Love
Is it true you met Tyler on Tinder it is
very true and I remember telling him you
know hope this doesn't bother you but I
have CP and he said well I'm pigeon toed
so I hope that doesn't bother you just
months into their relationship her life
changed again during a doctor's visit in
2016. these lumps were all throughout my
body and a couple weeks later I was
diagnosed with Hodgkin's lymphoma stage
3B it took 12 rounds of chemotherapy
before doctors said her scans were clear
Steph and Ty have since married and
faced the out outside world together
we've been in a grocery store and a man
has literally come up to him and shaken
his hand and said like so good of you to
be with her and like why isn't he lucky
to also be with me she can't stand but
she's a wheelchair for me yeah what
would your hope for Colby be gosh I mean
so many things you know as a mom you
just have all the Hope in the world you
know I used to think that because she
had CP she would be an artist because
she couldn't be an athlete and now I
know that the world is her oyster My
Hope Is that she's exactly who she wants
to be
and stuff I hope Colby just finds her
real voice she's capable of doing
anything I just hope that it's part of
her and that she's proud of it because
if I could go back to that five-year-old
girl I would doubt
if if I could go back to my
five-year-old self I would tell her to
be proud of herself
their weekend together was a blast Steph
took Colby and her little sister out for
some bike riding they played games
watched a movie it was truly one for the
books and they are hoping to plan
another trip soon but for now they will
be keeping up their very Lively very
loud we're told FaceTime sessions I
should mention that March is actually
National cerebral palsy Awareness Month
about 10 000 babies each year in the U.S
are diagnosed with CP and Steph wants
people to know CP is a spectrum and it's
something that Colby has picked up on
too Colby will say in fact my CP is
different than Steph's and we need help
in different ways so you see
representation matters it really does
number one I love Colby's little voice I
love the voices of little children I
love that so squeaky yes but I love
Colby and stuff together and I love the
messages that Steph is giving to Colby
that's right that it's a people will
stare but it's okay for you to say you
know it bothers me how how can I answer
your questions genius advice to give to
make you not feel as self-conscious and
I also like that she doesn't like it
when I love when she checked the guy in
the grocery store to say you know why
isn't he lucky to be with me that she
doesn't want to use it inspiration
because I always think inspiration is
good she says no don't say that yeah
yeah no it's absolutely it's like a note
or a younger self tucked in there Elaine
thank you we'll be right back really
good Elaine really good